Katie Holmes and daughter Suri Cruise  surprised fans at jingle ball I was  really excited  adorable mother-daughter duo stepped out  together Friday night for the z100 New  York's I Heart Radio jingle ball at  Madison Square Garden the pair were all  smiles as they took the stage to  introduce Taylor Swift's performance  Surrey looked too cute in a black dress  with silver stars she paired with  pigtails and a big festive red bow while  her mama dressed chic in a long-sleeve  ruffled white colored top with black  pants and matching heels it was really a  lot of fun after Katie and Surrey  introduced Taylor set the 27 year old  singer was spotted out on the town with  boyfriend Joe Alwyn what should we need  to  you